ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dillon show very excited to have uh RFK
Jr on today who's running for president
and his wife Cheryl Hines uh 30 minutes
into the podcast we did have a weird
blackout in the studio it's never
happened before I've been podcasting
about seven years this has never
happened it was strange it happened uh
in the middle of the episode we lost
about 15 good minutes and then we got
back to it
um but as you know uh there you know it
kind of broke uh the uh you know we had
a groove going and it was fun we had a
dynamic and it was cool and when the
lights went off I think he thought
someone was trying to kill him
and you know because it's again it's the
family history
um but you know he's really
conscientious guy but you know when
those lights went down he was like
Pharaoh like he they were you know it
got strange so he's a great guy I would
love to see him uh you know gain
Traction in this race because I think he
could be uh an incredibly
um amazing president you know when you
listen to the guy talk
um and his wife is lovely and amazing
and talented as well so they were great
but if there is a weirdness around the
middle of the episode we do address it
but it it it stopped and it started and
when that happens to a podcast
unfortunately it does kind of break the
Rhythm a little bit but they were great
Sports about it and there's some really
great information in this episode
um thank you here we go ladies and
gentlemen welcome to the Tim Dillon show
special episode today RFK Cheryl Hines
thank you guys for both coming uh I
appreciate appreciate it fellow
Californians uh coming here I appreciate
it it's a you know we get a lot of bad
press as a state some of it is deserved
you've been living here how long
2014 I'm out here so nine years and what
do you think of it
well you know I didn't want to move out
I moved out for love because I actually
had a you know I had it live and a
profession in New York right and um but
Cheryl couldn't move and then none of my
kids wanted to move
and then we got out here and now they
all love it here so you know I mean
there's you can't beat California first
of all if I don't know if you lived on
the East Coast I was a New Yorker yeah
you know I should have but I didn't you
know usually my mother or grandmother
did it it was good for them I figured
them on yeah I mean watched him through
the windows yeah I I mean but I I I I
have occasionally but yeah though you
can't beat the winters here uh when
they're nice when they're mild no
they're it's so beautiful and you have
the ocean in the mountains and it's
amazing it has everything so yeah it is
great and we have I think we're the
fourth largest economy in the World
Behind uh you know it's like GDP where
the fifth I mean it's in a it's a
massive engine of the American economy
um now you're somebody who who's been
open about your your struggles with with
drug and alcohol and coming out of that
when you see you know the the the
problem in California all over the
country but specifically because we all
live here
um in California with people that are
homeless that are addicted to drugs
um
how do you internalize that as somebody
who's been through that and you're
looking at people and you have
compassion but you know you also realize
that like it's becoming
um a massive problem and every time now
someone talks about California they
think about this uh issue where you have
people that are unable to live
um uh without you know being you know
really there's Mental Health crisis
hopelessly addicted to substances is
there a way can we do more I mean there
has to be a way to do more well I mean
there's two issues one is addiction
and the other is homelessness and I
don't think that they're necessarily
connected my son Connor
last night we were talking about this
issue and he said he pointed out that
um
that in West Virginia that there's more
drug addiction per capita there's more
poverty
um per capita and there is probably an
equal amount of mental illness and yet
there's no homelessness problem
and it has to do with the availability
of housing right uh so it's not uh
homelessness and addiction do not have
to go hand in hand right if you solve
the housing issue you know one of the
reasons in San Francisco
that they have this terrible problem is
because they have zoning laws that don't
allow any high density housing and and
um and that that contributes to the
problem but I you know we were in San
Francisco recently when we tried the
Monsanto case
I was there almost for a year because
each of those three trials were about
three you know it required about you
know two or three months of their
and I would go to Union Square every day
uh to you know to exercise there's a it
was an equinox there and I uh
and you know I'd see the shops and you
had all of the great iconic American
stores you know at plus you had brought
on Gucci and then you went Gap and Old
Navy and
Levi's and you know
um Nordstroms and and Bloomingdale's and
all of these and it it's like fifth for
people who don't know of course oh there
was there's a part of San Francisco that
is like Fifth Avenue and it it is a
shopping City people tourists come all
over the world
the shop in Union Square the way that
they do in Fifth Avenue and today I went
up there I don't know if you've been up
there recently but I went up there a
month ago and every one of those stores
is is boarded up it's just acre after
acre of plywood it's like if you shut
down
Fifth Avenue I don't think people
understand what in the cataclysm that
has struck that City
and it's uh the the office space is 30
has a uh 65 percent
vacancy so it's a 35 occupancy rate they
built buildings
five years ago for 330 million dollars
and they're now selling them for 100
million and it's hard to see how
that City recovery even with really good
leadership you know those those
those are um those kind of stores take a
year to just you know to a runway on
them right you have to then make
commitments that are 10 or 20 or so well
a lot of people say those you know
California's Democrat Run State very few
Republicans uh San Francisco certainly I
don't think you have any Republicans
right so and people there has to be like
one or two there's one or two
Republicans but they're San Francisco
apartments right yeah so there's no way
so people are saying they're going to
say you're a Democrat you're running for
president what is different about the
way you would handle San Francisco and
certain issues in Los Angeles then what
Democrats have done in this state
well you know I I mean I have a I I have
ideas for how to handle those issues
that people can go on our website but
you know one of all right
I think housing is a critical issue and
it's not just critical for people in San
Francisco and our kids kids I might you
know I have Cheryl and I have seven kids
between 20 and 39.
and
um
and when I was that age I was already
thinking of you know buying a house or
how am I going to do it Etc where do I
want to live you know
and I don't know any of my kids friends
who are even thinking that a lot of them
are living with their parents
um and you know they they the chance of
them actually buying a house is unless
they do incredibly well their lives is
very very slim and my kids are
you know they they have good jobs they
make money but um but it's not enough to
buy a house and two years ago
you had uh you had the the average price
of a house was two hundred and fifteen
thousand dollars and even that was Out
Of Reach for a lot of in America that
was the average that was the average
across the country okay on the coast
it's much higher is the average today
it's four hundred thousand it's two
years ago and you're now paying you know
you were back then you're paying maybe
three percent interest now you're paying
seven percent interest
the house is three or four or five times
expensive and there's no way anyway and
then what everybody has this experience
of knowing somebody who is about to buy
a house and then somebody comes in just
before they go into escrow
somebody comes in with a cash offer and
snatches out from under them and this
this is just now a ubiquitous experience
and what's happening is not only are we
aren't we you know suffering inflation
from the constant Wars eight trillion
dollars on War
a trillion dollars that we didn't have
on regime change Awards since 2002
or also
um you have these three giant companies
BlackRock State Street and Vanguard who
own who all own each other you know
BlackRock has 10 trillion dollars under
man these are all private Equity
companies yeah the biggest companies in
the world and they and they are they own
I think they own uh 88 of the s p 500s
those three companies say on 88 of the S
P 500 so they already own everything and
now they've decided
they're gonna buy every single family
home in America so
um they're on track Now to control to
own the corporate control of the 60 of
the of the single family homes in
America within six years so so you're
saying so when somebody comes in with a
cash offer it's it's usually from uh
it's an LLC with some ambiguous name a
shell Corp right and if you if you
follow the you know the breadcrumbs
it'll go back to it
Vanguard State Street and they want to
own all of them and you know and I mean
ironically and I you know I don't want
to feed into anybody's partner but
you know it's playing with matches and a
dynamite you know [__] yeah with you in
the room but uh yeah but Larry Fink
who's uh who is the CEO of BlackRock is
also on the board of the world economic
Forum yes which you know their Mantra is
we're going to have this great reset
what does that mean it means that and
this is these are their quotes not mine
you will own nothing and you will be
happy you'll be happy the famous article
I mean now they're doing I talked about
it last week in the show they're running
all these articles in Wall Street
Journal where they go it's now the trend
and not have a dining room you don't
need a living room all of these you know
the Publications are coming out and
they're going like Americans are are
they're they're happy with shrinking
houses and less space and and and and
then they talk about like home builders
are trying to figure out ways to like in
a challenging real estate market still
be profitable what they don't mention is
these home builders are not like Mom and
Pop contractors these are you know DH
Horton these are massive by BlackRock
State Street right so how is this
takeover of the of the American real
estate market uh how can this how is
this preventable well you know what what
I would do immediately there's a lot of
things you can do one is you can change
the tax code to make it
uh unprofitable because our kids are now
competing against black rocks and
BlackRock has a bottomless Bank book
it has the lowest interest rates on the
planet of anybody
and our kids now have to compete against
that company now why is their rates so
are they lending themselves money how
does it work well first of all they own
all the banks they own all the credit
card companies and they that helps just
because they have a huge Bank book The
you know the uh they're a safe loan so
there's zero risk in wanting to
Blackrock
and so the banks will give them the
lowest possible rates and our kids then
have to compete you know our kids who
have no credit rating who have you know
a 600 credit rate or whatever it is are
paying not seven percent but maybe 10
interest right and they're competing
against somebody that's that's getting
three percent interest
it's all right and you know we have an
American Dream in this country the
promise as World War II your parents
generation my parents generation if you
worked hard if he played by the rules
you could have one job not three and you
can own a house you could take a summer
vacation you could raise a family and
you could and you could put away money
for retirement
that is just not even for anybody that
is not true over now that's over these
kids are not going to own homes and and
if you don't own a home
you don't care about your community you
don't care about the schools you don't
care you know you that you're less
vested you're less vested and so you're
not you're not you know you're not doing
the things that homeowners do to take
care of them to invest in their
Community to to make it a better place
to live so
and you also have no access to Capital
because
you know if you are a homeowner and you
want to start a small business and you
want to take a risk you get a second
mortgage on your home and you have some
access to Capital because you have an
asset
you can go to the bank with and say look
I I know this may be stupid but I'm
going to start a in our restaurant and
I'm going to put up my home as
collateral and I'm going to do it so but
if you don't have a home
you have no access to Capital that's a
great Point somebody else no way right
to tap the equity in your home you know
you're you're you're you're you're
you're cut off from that source of money
you're also I think people that are are
not homeowners are subject to the rising
rents yeah all the time
you have no control and the ownership by
these companies
is driving up the cost of rents 48 of
people in this country who are renting
are are have anxiety and Cheryl and I
talk about this all the time
you're living paycheck to paycheck in
this country
you know and and and
57 of Americans cannot put their hands
on a thousand dollars if they have
emergency right if you're living
paycheck you are not that fewer than
half of those people are making enough
money to pay for basic human needs for
food transportation and uh and housing
if he and Cheryl you know made this
point to me about when she you know
because she spent most of her life
living paycheck to paycheck right he
said the engine light would come on in
her car and it's like the apocalypse
yeah you know you don't have the money
to pay the mechanic you can't put your
hands on that money and you know that
car is gonna die but you have to get to
work yeah you can't get to work what
happens if you don't have a card you
can't get to work yeah and everything
then starts spiraling to you end up on
the street well it's like you know I
remember being broke being a a comedian
and just trying to make it and like it's
tough to you know opening bank accounts
it's hard yeah you know I was climbing
out of poverty and the type of poverty
that you know we're not talking about
people that are momentarily broke or
talk about in many cases generational
poverty people aren't inheriting homes
they're not you know they're still
locked out of the system in many ways
they are their credit rating is is tough
maybe they maybe they got busted for
smoking weed or there's some you know
criminal record that's preventing them
from getting the job they want the
Democratic party had always styled
itself as kind of the defender of
working people and the defender of
economic Justice what happened
I mean now
I saw this data the other day and I
haven't traced it down to you know
verify it but I what I read the other
day was that 70 of the wealth in this
country is now controlled by Democrat
um versus 30 play Independence and
Republicans and
um so and at the time 10 of the nine of
the ten top
richest counties are now Democrat
counties so it used to be this is
flip-flop from where it was when I was a
kid
where the Republicans were were the rich
with the oligarchs
and the um and the Democrats are you
know working uh working for working
people right
and so it has flipped and you know and
uh uh you're asking me well I I don't
know it exactly no I saw I watched it
happen
let me just finish the yeah this is
interesting Democratic counties
represent 70 percent of U.S GDP 2020
election shows so that's the 2020
elections chaotic and marked by race is
too close to call have nonetheless
reaffirmed that at least in Washington
the two parties now speak for markedly
different segments of the U.S economy
yeah I mean that's that's very
interesting yeah because when you and I
were growing up the Democrats
represented the poor in them that's
right yeah
and the Republicans represented Wall
Street in the oligarchy
but one of the things that I'm going to
do I'm I'm going to immediately create a
new class of mortgages that you know if
you have a rich uncle
you can get a much lower mortgage rate
if if he will close on your loan
go sign your mortgage you can get it
because the bank is looking at his bank
book
other than yours and they're going to
give them a better rate because it's a
lower risk what I'm going to do is I'm
going to give everybody a rich Uncle
which is going to be Uncle Sam and I'm
going to Uncle Sam to co-sign this new
class of mortgages that people get for
three percent
only first-time individual homeowners
can get it
they have to live in that community and
they have to work in that community and
I'm going to give the first 500 000 A's
to teachers because we need to start
supporting our teachers and allow them
to live near the schools and work in
those those places and with the way
and I'm going to finance those mortgages
not by increasing our debt which we
should not be doing
uh the I by selling
um three percent bonds that are tax-free
so the market will snap up those bonds
and uh and we'll be able to finance
mortgages so your kids
now will be paying a thousand dollars it
will take a thousand dollars a month off
the typical mortgage of our average
mortgage and you can now get a thousand
a a home for a thousand dollars a month
and uh you know people are paying rent
that for rent and you're building a
middle class and you know when we built
the middle class in this country
after World War II we built a middle
class that became the greatest economic
generator in the history of mankind and
uh we owned when I was a boy half the
wealth on the face of the Earth because
of the American middle class
and now we're tearing it apart and uh
but it began by by making sure everybody
could get into a house after World War
II the GI bill or these other
programs that allowed every American in
my house and once you buy a house you
have access to Capital you can start a
business if you're entrepreneurial and
it released the you know these what
which Franklin Roosevelt called
America's industrial genius you know the
the
inclination for Innovation for
entrepreneurship for
um you know for business development
you can't do that if the if the middle
class does not have access to Capital
which means if they have no equity if
they're living in a rental home you
cannot rebuild them you need to get them
into their own homes how do you stop the
BlackRock Vanguard State Street from
cannibalizing the real estate that we
have in America right now well they're
doing too with a farm real estate and in
fact
that's one of the reasons for the
Ukraine war is that they you know we're
loaning 140 billion dollars a year for
to Ukraine and they're paying it back by
you know we force them to do this
through austerity programs
and it's part of our contract where they
have to put all the Farmland in Ukraine
up for sale it's called the land market
and
um and BlackRock is over there buying
you know the corporations have snapped
up 28 of this is the richest Farmland in
the world I'm so stunned and shocked by
by that it is so shy can you imagine
that what I mean how do you but yeah
how do you stop that you do it you do it
through the tax card I mean we I believe
in free market capitalism sure I don't
believe well we don't have we don't have
that now what we have is Corporate crony
capitalism and Monopoly capitalism
and you need to start uh enforcing the
antitrust laws which is one of the
reasons BlackRock is getting away with
murder they're you know they they're
they own all these industries that
they've Consolidated they've vertically
integrated them
and they shouldn't be allowed to do that
when we're dealing with this now in
Cheryl's business and my business to a
lesser degree uh with the the strike
with sag and the WJ because a lot of the
streamers and the Studios in Hollywood
it's also vertical integration where you
have you know that type of cronyism
where you have all those kind of you
know fixing prices and fixing costs of
Labor and stuff and that is kills
capitalism it kills competition it kills
the thing uh that we all know is
responsible for some of the great
Innovations we enjoy and the standard of
living that we used to have so you're
coming up because you you let a lot of
people during the last election cycle
with Bernie Sanders that were saying
they were giving up on capitalism that
they felt like uh especially the younger
generation right younger people are
identifying more with socialism than any
other generation prior to them because I
think they've looked at uh the rising
inequality they've looked at how corrupt
Everything feels
um yeah I would say that one of the
reasons for that is that
they're looking at BlackRock and they're
saying that's capitalism right and we
reject it but that's not capitalism no
that's just you know it's a it's
plutocracy it's a you know it's uh
it's this uh it's a corporate
kleptocracy that's what it is it's
Monopoly so you do you cap the amount of
homes that that those well you what you
do is you say you know you change the
tax code
so that they to penalize corporations
who own over a certain number of homes
that they you know you have to uh and
you can do that in a million different
ways but you know that what we should be
doing is we should be lifting the
regulatory burden on small business
right and increasing it on these on
large businesses you know across the
board on environmental uh regulations on
worker safety on all of the different
issues
you need to go easier on small business
yeah and I'm not saying you know you
know let them abuse workers or or poison
the environment and I'm saying most of
the problems are coming from the top oh
yeah and they get economies of scale and
so they get you know they get to buy the
subsidized corn they are the ones who
get this corn subsidies they're the ones
that from
I'm cradle to get grave everything they
do is subsidized because they got the
big lobbyists on Capitol Hill or you
know or
writing the rules that
um that favor these you know these
monopolistic incumbents
and punish the little guy in our country
and we got to dismantle that and do you
know we
listen we lost uh we lost our democracy
once before we lost it during the Gilded
Age in the 1880s and 1890s
and we lost uh we're not lost free
market capitalism too you had you know a
straight out Monopoly capitalism the
railroads the sugar trust uh
cotton trust the the uh the steel trust
all of them were you know they had these
interlocking boards
back then you didn't have direct
election of senators so the senators
were chosen by the legislatures and they
owned the legislatures outright
and you know it was said about the
Pennsylvania state legislature and none
of them could be bought because John D
Rockefeller owned them all and he
wouldn't sell any
right and that's how it was with all the
legislatures in our country they were
owned by these big corporations
so they controlled the Senate they
controlled the government and you know
we had now even though we're electing
these Senators directly it feels like
they're owned by the same corporate
interests exactly after the citizens
united case in 2008
we're back where we were during the
1880s and citizens united basically
allowed money to be looked at as free
speech one of the things I did to break
up you know they did a whole bunch of
things in the early 1900s you had
uh corporate income tax come in for the
first time the 40-hour work week you had
you know unions basically legalized you
had
um uh you had women get the vote
you had a man's unchild labor you had uh
and then you had uh the Sherman
Antitrust Act was passed in 1903.
in 1908 they passed a law making it
illegal for corporations to donate to
Federal political campaigns so and all
of those reforms and then you had Teddy
Roosevelt come in
um you had these you know movements you
first of all you had great journalism
and these muck raking journalists like I
had a Tarbell and and Sinclair Lewis and
the person who wrote that thing about
the meat factory yeah yeah yeah
who were exposing corporate corruption
and you know McClure's magazine was was
and I had a Tarbell did these uh Xmas a
of the Standard Oil company and John D
Rockefeller every American was reading
it they were all pissed off
you had a populist movement in the
countryside that that popped up that was
Democratic a a progressive movement in
the cities that was Republican but they
all ended up getting together they
elected Teddy Roosevelt he went in and
bashed
in a dismantled Standard Oil which was
the mother of all monopolies and uh and
you know we got our democracy back right
and then in exactly 100 years later I
think 2008 citizens united cases pass is
that that ruling comes down from the
Supreme Court
it throws out this Hundred Year law this
100 year old law that had said
corporations can't give to the political
process
and so we threw that out and you know a
corporate our own Supreme Court throws
that out in 2008
and then or 2006 I forgot which but they
then you had this just wall the tsunami
of money pouring in and now
you know Democratic party right now has
two billion dollars well how do you get
two billion dollars it's with Joe Biden
sitting in the basement calling you know
billionaires and 100 millionaires or
someone calling on his behalf or calling
on his behalf right and you know the
Senate you're not allowed to make those
calls from the Senate Office Building
right right
so the political parties of erected
buildings right next to the Senate and
as soon as the Senators vote they go
over these call centers and they sit on
the telephone and they make two or three
hundred calls a day
but if that's what you're doing you have
to you each one of those owners you have
to get ten thousand dollars from them
and if you are doing that you do not
have time if you need to raise 50
million to run for Senate from ten
thousand dollar donors you got no time
to talk to the little guy right oh
they're living in a bubble we're the
only people who matter to them are the
people who can write a ten thousand
dollar check
and everybody else becomes invisible to
them and that's why to me
Donald Trump rolled across this country
because all of these people in you know
Pennsylvania and Ohio
who are watching their lives deteriorate
their kids can't buy houses they're
being their Wells are being poisoned you
know their lives are upended and and uh
and they're
they're in this Dad this terrible dad
and they and no and living paycheck to
paycheck like Cheryl says
and nobody's listening to them they feel
like nobody is paying attention to them
nobody is hearing them right now
the average
income in this country the average
income is five thousand dollars less
than the cost of basic human needs so
you know food what is the average income
in America I don't know I I think it's
around thirty four thousand Thirty
thirty five thousand I believe it's
around 34th and so you're saying that
that is this true well this is as of
about
it that's tough yeah but in order to
live you need 36 right so what they're
doing is Americans I have a 5 000 on
average average American that's a five
thousand dollar deficit every year
they're putting that on their credit
card the credit card companies are
getting 22 percent and which if the
mafia gave you that they would go out to
jail for lawn shortening right
that is coming from you know Chase
Manhattan and Wells Fargo and the worst
culprits are visas and Masters car those
are they have these little cars when I
was really confident they send you a
card that has a 250 activation fee yeah
to just activate the card and the limit
might be three hundred dollars so
literally I had one of these credit
cards when I had like no money yeah and
you know you go out to dinner because
you're like okay I have a credit card
now and you know you're not making the
best financial decisions but then it
like does it work and then you go I have
room on this and they go no that the
activation fee is 250. like and then the
interest you pay is so crazy so that
cycle of poverty is very hard up to
escape those companies who owns Visa I'm
gonna take a guess and say BlackRock and
garden stage three so they're just
they're what they think I'm like a big
vacuum cleaner yeah like so it's a black
rocks you just walk through Washington
like lighting things on fire just
parking on the lawn of the White House
like I I love expressvpn everybody on
the team uses it everyone I know uses it
my friends my family and pretty much
everyone I've ever met uh every time you
connect to an unencrypted Network in
cafes hotels airports your online data
is not secured this is very tough it
didn't take a hacker with a super
computer over a billion years to get
past expressvpn's encryption uh vpn's
virtual private Network it scrambles
your IP address make sure that hackers
cannot gain access to and steal your
personal data expressvpn works on all
your devices phone laptop tablet even
your smart TV it's so easy to use just
fire up the app and click one button and
get protected
I love it I use it everyone uses it that
I've ever met are they wrong is everyone
I've ever met wrong
get an extra three months free of
expressvpn at expressvpn.com Tim Dillon
that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com Tim Dillon e x p r
e s s vpn.com Tim Dylan do it baby do it
now get it done can you believe we've
had seven months without an NFL game
crazy right well good thing that's over
Annabelle is here in DraftKings
Sportsbook an official sports betting
partner of the NFL is giving you uh a
can miss offer for week one this week
new customers can get two hundred
dollars in bonus bets instantly when you
bet just five bucks on an NFL game
DraftKings is hooking up everybody with
game day greatness all customers can
take advantage of two new offers every
single game day this September check the
app check the app to see what you got
download now use code Tim Dillon
to sign up new customers can take them
two hundred dollars in bonus bets
instantly go do it right now go download
this app right now it's fun to bet you
make money
download you get 200 in bonus bets
instantly just for betting five bucks
code Tim Dillon d-i-l-l-o-n only on
DraftKings sports book an official
sports betting partner of the NFL the
crown is yours gambling problem call
1-800 Gambler visit www.1800 gambler.net
New York call 8778 Hope New York and
text Hope New York in Connecticut help
is available for problem gambling call
888-789-777 or visit
ccpg.org please play responsibly on
behalf of Boot Hill Casino and Resort 21
plus age varies by jurisdiction void in
Ontario
c c d k n g dot Co slash football for
eligibility terms and responsible gaming
resources bonus bets expire seven days
after insurance eligibility and deposit
restrictions apply okay so we had a
blackout folks in the middle of the
episode we lost a lot of stuff we had no
idea why that has never happened ever
here once that we've recorded
um and uh you know this is fun so we
lost a lot of stuff and we're back and
we're gonna go through it again but it
was a blackout in the studio and it's
just fun you've had fire alarms at your
speeches pulled and who knows not
sounding paranoid not sounding paranoid
Black Rock State Street Vanguard we
don't know what happened but uh we'll
we'll say this well we we were in a
great discussion about the Ukraine war
um because we spent eight trillion
dollars on Wars we've spent all of these
all of these interventions that we had
after 9 11 where all of these The
Architects of them these Neon
conservatives after that you know they
were shut out of government right they
kind of laughed they were disgraced
another popping up again they're popping
up again as Democrats and they are the
main a lot of them are uh some of the
main uh promoters of the idea of this
endless war in the Ukraine yeah and I
mean that's one of my
one of the things my uncle figured out
when he uh four months into his
administration you know he had been
warned by Eisenhower about the emergence
of the military industrial complex which
would turn America into an imperial
State abroad
and a surveillance State a Garrison
State a Security State at home and you
know Eisenhower had said the thing that
our founding fathers had said
you cannot maintain democracy if you're
an imperial State abroad you're gonna
you know you'll bankrupt the middle
class you'll
you'll turn us into a surveillance day
my uncle four months in recognized that
you know when he was lied to by the CIA
by Alan Dallas Charles Richard Bissell
and by the military brass about the pigs
and when the men were dying on the beach
you know he took public blame for it but
he privately told his aides I want to
take the CIA shattered into a thousand
pieces and Scatter it to the winds
and um and then he fired Alan Dulles
Richard Bissell and Charles Cabell the
guys who were directly responsible for
lying to him but for the next Thousand
Days his administration he was in a
pitched battle
to keep our country out of War they
wanted the wars because that was that he
recognized that their job had devolved
into providing the military-industrial
complex military contractors a constant
pipeline of new orders to feed their
profits well
and you know the neocons uh which are
neoconservatives for people who don't
know it's a movement that started in uh
early 1990s around 92 and uh
when the Berlin Wall came down and they
published a document that called a
project for New American Century that
said that because we were the Victor in
the cold war that America now had
the uh the right to rule the world uh
for a century or more at by using its
Superior military Powers the unit power
so after 2001 we spent between then and
now we've spent eight trillion dollars
on Wars on regime change Wars it was
Iraq war and then all these spillover
wars in Yemen Libya Syria Pakistan and
Afghanistan
Etc what did we get for those Wars
here's what we got Iran Iraq is now
worse off than we found it it's an
incoherent kind of battle between Shia
and Sunni death squads
we killed more Iraqis than Saddam
Hussein
we pushed we killed between 650 000 a
million Iraqis
we
have pushed Iraq into a proxy posture
with Iran which is exactly the foreign
policy outcome we've been trying to
avoid for decades uh we in the spillover
war in Syria we created Isis
we sent two million refugees into Europe
and destabilize every democracy in
Europe you know we we created brexit
right the riots that are now happening
in France her direct result of that
those Wars
and we bankrupted the American middle
class because we didn't have the money
to pay for them so and that is you know
what we got and then we're given these
kind of comic book depictions
each time you know whether it's Gaddafi
whether it's a Saddam or given this this
this caricature of you know okay there's
a bad guy here and there's a good guy
we're the good guys we're always the
good guys and here's the bad guy and
it's a
it's a black and white debate there is
no question about it if you side with
the bad guy if you question ask
questions about you know the action
it means you're on the side of Putin or
something right right and that that
whole game
so
um the the what happened I mean the
thing people should know about Ukraine
war we were told it's you know Putin
wants to be the new Hitler he wants to
invade Europe and right right and but
when you look at what actually happened
it's much more complex than that and
much more nuanced
Putin actually steadfastly resisted
going to war he's he has said and that
Russians not just Putin but all the
Russian leaderships had said since 1992.
if you move NATO to the east you're
going to provoke a violent response we
you know
uh
Russia's been invaded three times
through Ukraine
the last time Hitler killed one out of
every seven Russians so they they you
know it's a national security priority
for them
a Ukraine cannot be under the control of
a hostile foreign power they can't
tolerate that and all of our greatest
diplomats George Cannon who was the
architect of the
entertainment policy after World War II
have constantly reiterated that if you
go into Ukraine with NATO you're going
to force Russians to have the violent
response
also I here's what happened in 2014
we put five billion dollars
into the med on into funding the Madonna
Rebellion which is this you know
Uprising in Ukraine against
the duly elected governments of the
Ukraine which was neutral and maybe
leaned a little towards Russia but we
wanted them out and we paid five billion
dollars to in a in a series of
demonstrations that ended in a coup
d'etat against that regime
and the installation of a pro-american
regime
Putin wants to settle things immediately
the first thing that new pro-american
regime did was it made it illegal to
speak the Russian language
and it um banned Russian political
parties too right yes yeah and when the
when Russian ethnic Russians
which are 90 of that population when
they began peaceful demonstrations they
were attacked violently and ultimately
they it started a civil war or 14 000
more killed the Civil War really began
in 2014. Russia
tried to sell it the people of those
provinces voted
to join the Russian Union right and and
Putin said no so this is not consistent
with the portrait of him
and then he said we need a peace treaty
it protects these people I don't want to
go in there but we need a peace treaty
and he agreed he negotiated with
France Germany England and
um and the U and Ukraine
on a peace treaty to organize a pastry
called the minska courts that would have
left
part of Ukraine as a semi-autonomous
region able to speak their own language
and that would have permanently kept
NATO out of Ukraine it was a reasonable
settlement
um
zolenski who's a comedian and an actor
campaigns in 2019 and wins he has no
political experience but he wins in a
landslide 70 percent of ukrainians
support him why he went in on one issue
peace
he said I'm going to sign the Mexican
cords and I'm going to get a ratified in
the Ukrainian Parliament Ukrainian
people did not want a war and wanted
peace
he gets in there and suddenly he pivots
now why did he pivot nobody knows but I
think it's fair gas and he pivoted for
two reasons one is that Ultra naturalist
in his government and he is Italian
um told him that they would kill him if
he negotiated a piece with Russia and
neocons particularly Victorian Newland
in the U.S White House and state
department told him the same thing that
he could not sign a peace Accord so he
abandons it
Russia goes in Putin goes in but only
with 40 000 people
well he's got a lot more he's got a
million 1.2 million reserves but he only
sends 40 000 people in there why
this is a nation of 44 million people
Ukraine oh merely he's not trying to
conquer Ukraine with 40 000 troops right
he wanted to bring us the negotiating
table so and this and this they go in in
January
in March almost nobody's been killed at
that point comparative what's happened
now
he says okay let's negotiate peace he
comes back to the negotiating table
and they if the U.S won't help him
oh he has to go to Israel and Turkey to
get their help negotiating a peace
Accord they negotiate a peace Accord
which is uh which is Minsk Accords 2.0
with Putin
lensky initials it the Russians initial
it and the Russians start withdrawing
their troops from Ukraine in good faith
what happens then Biden
sends Boris Johnson over there the UK
prime minister to torpedo that peace
agreement and uh
and he and the landforcelinski to
tearing up and since then
400 000 Ukrainian kids have been killed
on the front lines and I and you know
all of those kids and mothers and every
one of those lives was an unnecessary
tragedy and you know you know my son
went over there and fought I did not
know that but I I had heard something
like that and that's amazing
well he and I
disagreed with the war yeah you know I
have tremendous respect for him and he
believed what he was doing he had great
sympathy Ukrainian people which I share
with Cheryl and I share of course he had
were never the ones
right and um I that's that's a badass
thing for him to do it shows his
character to go over there and and fight
with Ukrainian people I mean we didn't
know that he was going yeah I would not
help if Manhattan Beach was invaded you
know what I mean like I wouldn't even do
that so the idea
yeah I would tweet about it so sad the
ransacking of Manhattan Beach I would
not who cares
I'm unaffected but no that's that's an
amazing thing and what uh is is he still
there is he oh he's back but he was in
he fought in the court keep offensive he
was a
machined on Earth I mean you tell what
happened yeah I mean well he he
he
told us he was going somewhere but
wouldn't tell us where yeah um because
he said he didn't want us to be worried
yeah this would qualify as worry yeah
and then so after he left of course we
were worried because you know if
somebody says don't worry right I'm
gonna be okay it's like
what well what are you doing right um
and then we started seeing some credit
card uh charges in Poland and we you
know put two and two together and right
but we couldn't reach him we couldn't we
couldn't communicate with him right it
was really it was very it was very
stressful so he was joined a special
forces
um uh unit he was uh in the Foreign
Legion
Ukraine important Legion and he fought
in that offensive as a machine gunner
first the Drone operator which is the
most dangerous job because the Russians
can tell as soon as you turn on that
drone and then they and it's our
children they send artillery the
artillery kills anything within 300 feet
um and and then he became a machine
gunner and
um he uh and you know now he's back and
he's he just graduated law school so he
says thank God
but all I talked to him yesterday and
all of the people that he served with
have either been killed or are
hospitalized you know
it's it's it's terrible
um but you gave a great succinct
explanation I think a lot of people are
confused about
uh why we're not trying to negotiate a
settlement why we're not trying to force
peace talks why that isn't something
that we're requiring along with all of
these donations and or I mean all of the
funding and the Weaponry
um but I think you know it's it's pretty
clear to a lot of people that we may not
want peace talks that well and you know
there's people making a lot of money on
this and
um when you know we committed uh now 140
billion you know if if Biden gets the
extra 24 billion that he's looking for
oh but in March we opted to 113 billion
well the entire budget of EPA is 12
billion so that's all we've got for the
environment this country well we have 10
times at
or Ukraine and um you know we're having
crisis here yeah we have a lot of we
have millions of people in the US that
can't eat that don't have enough it has
a lot of problems 35 of America's
resources are not making enough to pay
for basic human needs and those people
are on the edge of becoming homeless and
it's a crisis
um well the entire budget for CDC is 12
million
when we got 10 times that again
when Mitch McConnell was asked in March
why are we in the um why are we in the
Ukraine why do we have enough money for
this where's the money coming from he
said don't worry about it
because that money's not really going to
Ukraine it's going to U.S military
contractors Raytheon General Dynamics
Boeing Lockheed
and you know so he admitted it it's just
a big money laundering scheme to the
military industrial complex and then if
you look
who do you think actually owns all of
those companies Steve Vanguard BlackRock
exactly yes now you see it all goes back
to that yeah they're they're strip
mining the wealth from the American
middle class and shifting it upward
through all of these different
mechanisms they're literally control
everything so I mean and no one's
talking about this which is interesting
the Republicans aren't talking about it
the Democrats aren't talking about it
um you're the only candidate out there
kind of bringing up these issues in this
way the media has been kind of
dismissive of you outright hostile and
now they're saying they want you to pay
for the Democratic dncs and they want
you to pay for primaries well that's one
of the things they're talking about the
dnc's does not want me in the primary
they
um
you know they have the candidates that
they want who's President Biden they
don't want him to debate they don't want
him to do retail politics they don't
want him to have unscripted uh
conversations with
uh with voters and they definitely don't
want him to debate me
and so there I they look at me I think I
feel
um although I haven't spoken to them
directly I've written them but have not
gotten reply
as a colossal nuisance and
um and they're trying to they're doing
everything they can to fix the results
so
one of the things they've done is
they've made it so that
um any vote that I get in Iowa or New
Hampshire
uh will count for Biden
and that and they're trying to do the
same thing now in Georgia they're trying
how are they doing that well they're
passing a rule that if you
any candidate who steps into the state
of New Hampshire Iowa to campaign
um we'll lose all their delegates
and
um and so I've campaigned in both days
so I lose their delegates but now what
they're trying to do is is and they
we're going to know on September 14th
where they actually do it
is they're trying to pass another rule
that if you step foot in New Hampshire
or Iowa
that any vote you get in New in Georgia
which is a big big delicate State
um we'll also
account for the president and not for
um you know so they're basically
disenfranchising everybody in those
States so there's no campaign and
they're talking about
this idea of making myself and Marianne
Williamson as the other Democratic
candidate to pay for all the primaries
ourselves are you enjoying this process
Cheryl of running for president
doesn't that sound fine I mean it sounds
fun I mean is this fun for you you're an
accomplished actress and comedian and
like you know is this fun going all over
the place and meeting people I'm sure it
has its challenges but is it enjoyable
at all you know it's to interesting
because I did not think that it would be
fun of course being honest of course I
don't like crowds yeah but she's like
hostile you know of course yeah he's a
comedian right well yeah it makes people
happy right people laugh yeah but it was
interesting because I I met Bobby in
South Carolina and I thought I would
just you know sit in the hotel room and
wait till he got home yeah
um but then I went out with him
everywhere and it was so interesting
because
I don't know when in my life I would ha
I would be going to like small
communities right in South Carolina and
just meeting people just listening to
people
um and it's it's very
um
sweet actually and it's very eye-opening
yeah because you live a lot of people
live in your space your right Town your
city wherever and
um and so you get wrapped up in what's
going on in your city and what's going
on in Los Angeles is not necessarily a
reflection of what's going on right in
Middle America so right it's so really
interesting to to sit down and talk to
people and hear what they're going
through and what their struggles are and
what their hopes are
um it's a really
um sort of magical way to see people
yeah and I know that you were an
environmentalist for a long time this is
a big part of your career people don't
know that but you were somebody who's
out there trying to protect
um things like national parks and rivers
and folks I don't even like national
parks and I I'm kind of I anti them
because everyone disappears in them and
but the reality is they have some
benefits but there's there's a lot of
things
I've said that many times national parks
right here so if you're in there it's
like you're looking for a problem
um I like cities and and you know
industrial things the crime happening
yeah yeah I want more of that I don't
like this big expansion but you have
tried to protect uh the environment yeah
I mean why I ran a big
uh the biggest uh and found it the
biggest what is now the biggest water
protection group in the world which is
water keeper Alliance and I went to work
in 1966 for I mean in 1984 for a blue
collar Coalition of commercial and
recreational fishermen
whose lives and livelihoods were being
destroyed by pollution on the Hudson and
we started suing polluters and I you
know represented them in over 500 cases
um against Hudson River polluters we
forced polluters to spend five and a
half billion dollars on
uh penalties on remediation
um and today the Hudson is the richest
waterway in the North Atlantic so it
produces more pounds of fish per acre
more biomass per gallon
than any other waterway in the Atlantic
Ocean north the Equator is the last
major river system left that has a
strong spawning stocks of all of its
historical species of migratory fish
and the miraculous Resurrection the
Hudson spawned the creation of of of now
350 water keepers
all over the world were in 46 countries
where on most of the waterways in the
United States we have them here on Santa
Monica Bay each one has a patrol boat we
Patrol the waterways we track down
polluters and we sue them but we're a
law enforcement group
yeah and it's not and it's not just
water I mean I watched him and his uh
Law Firm Sue Monsanto because of the
Roundup so you know Roundup is a weed
killer and there was one man who was a
groundskeeper at a school who would wear
Roundup on his back you know like on a
tank on his back and he started getting
lesions and reached out to uh Monsanto
and said is it possible that right this
is giving me lesions and so when when
they said and I never called him they
never called him they discussed but
internally and made a decision we better
not call him back because it probably is
yeah it's causing and so uh so so
something like that where they they sued
Monsanto and they you know it's clear
that Roundup did cause lesions and he he
got uh Non-Hodgkin's lymphoma
um
but just the idea of standing up against
these huge corporations and in this case
it was on behalf of one man but of
course there were lots of cases all over
the country yeah
um but being able to say it's not okay
you guys knew that it was killing people
right we have here's your email Trail
um and and then to win against Monsanto
it's a huge series it's a huge victory
yeah and it presents
um you know
companies that got corporations like
that you know in the future from you
know utilizing those same types of
dangerous chemicals and I mean what
about the food in this country the food
is incredibly unhealthy and polluted and
you go to Europe and other places you're
not allowed to put certain things in
food like GMOs right right and that's
why a lot of people you know eat we were
talking the other day eating bread or
pasta in this country and they get
gluten allergies celiac disease all
these allergic reactions
then they go to Italy and they can eat
it without any consequence and that's
because I I've been suing the
agricultural industry for now 40 years I
probably you know brought as many
lawsuits against the big companies like
Smithfield uh
uh Tyson's Pilgrim Purdue the big animal
factories that are creating a lot of the
pollution
uh probably bought more than any other
attorney against those companies and um
and one uh and you know but I I've
watched the corruption and the capture
of the Department of Agriculture by big
Agriculture and just
USDA was created to protect the small
farmer and to ensure as a wholesome food
supply and today the function of that
agency
is to destroy for the small farmers to
um to you know to create a safe spot
from Monsanto and Cargill and all of
these big agricultural BMS industrial
agricultural polluters
and chemical Agriculture and
the food that we get from that process
is not really food it's a it's filler
that you know has all kinds of poisons
in it and it lacks almost any
nutritional value right
and we're poisoning a whole generation
of Americans we now have the highest
chronic disease rate of any country in
the world
and because of that we pay them biggest
Health bills we pay
or 0.3 trillion dollars a year in
healthcare
and that's two or three or four times
more per capita than any other country
and
we have the worst health results so we
you know we have I think we're 79th now
in terms of health outcomes behind
Mongolia behind Cuba
and during covet we had the highest
coveted body count of any country in the
world we we have
uh we have 4.2 percent of the global
population but we had 16 percent of the
club of the deaths so
we at the highest kill rate of any
country in the world and you know why
they're giving people awards for that
million dollar prizes Etc
um when we had the worst record for
caring for Americans of Any Nation we
had 200 times the death rate of Nigeria
so do we need more regulation
well what we need is less
um do you surround yourself with guns
you've got to get rid of the agency
capture you've got to get rid of the
financial entanglements and these
perverse incentives right
um that give advantage to the you know
to the uh chemical agriculture over you
know regenerative farming and we we need
to
actually support farmers who want to
take care of the soil who want to
produce healthy nutritious foods for
Americans and that's what you know
that's what I'm going to do I know how
to do it
this is your wheelhouse because you guys
actually met at an environmental event
we did yes yeah we met at a water keeper
event okay it was a skiing it was a it
was it was a fundraiser so it was a
skiing event and um and Larry was on his
way and he's like you want to go with me
and I said uh yeah okay and then we got
there and then we met Bobby and um and
that I mean I made them skinny they
didn't I didn't want to ski oh I didn't
think we were going to ski yeah
um but they they came and then that was
sick and then both of us were married at
that time right oh we didn't you know
nothing
um there was no like spark turning into
a flame but then
I think six or seven years later Larry
brought her back to another and I was
very good friends with Larry I lived
with him for two summers we went on all
of our family vacations together
and he had just started curb the first
time right I mean Curb Your Enthusiasm
and that was the first time I met Cheryl
and she came back six years and we were
kind of friendly but you know
and then it never really saw you right
right but then yeah then I was I was
going through a divorce and he was going
through a divorce and it was like oh hi
oh hi right how are you fun yeah yeah
interesting and what's it like being now
I'm kind of member of the Kennedy family
and this has got to be this is a very
interesting family to to to marry into
yeah it is it is it is it's and it is
interesting yes on you know on one level
there just a family right everybody sits
around and we play charades and it's
right fun and is that what you guys said
I don't think Kennedys are doing are
they playing charades that's not what we
thought okay okay
very competitive game I I would imagine
they're competitive yeah oh my gosh yeah
um so on one hand you know you have that
and then on the other hand you know I
don't know your play Trivial Pursuit and
it's like oh your uncle you know and
that's weird right because it's like
this yeah worldwide
uh well it's like this legendary
American family that you're now a part
of yeah yeah I mean interesting it's
amazing how have the how has the
response been from the family to you
running is this good is this mixed is it
it's a big family right I would say if
they all voted or I think there was 105
of us at the cave um over Fourth of July
weekend
if they all had to vote I would I think
I think Biden would beat me
my family loves him okay
his family yes yes I have a lot of
people who support me in our family but
probably slightly more than our uh I
don't know I mean they're
they're
um
uh you know I feel loved by my whole
family right so I don't feel like it's I
think that you know but is it fair to
say that there's some people in the
family they're institutionalists and
yeah and there you know there's five
members of my family that work or Biden
in the administration and everybody in
my family that's awkward
[Laughter]
a little awkward yeah yeah yeah gotcha
okay I love neutral fall
I use it and so should you
I'm telling you
you don't have to choose between better
hair growth in your health neutralfold
provides whole body health approach for
men that promotes healthier hair no
drugs no compromises just better hair
men think losing their hair is
inevitable take control of your hair's
future with neutrophil it assigns back
hair growth supplements in it for men
that's the thing that we're doing here
did you know that 80 of men will
experience hair thinning in their
lifetime it's normal but it doesn't have
to be your fate you can get ahead of
thinning with neutrifol man tired of
weakening or thinning hair do you want
to reach your full hair potential
leading hair growth supplement
neutrophil improves your hair growth
you get visible thickness and visible
scalp coverage
it's the number one dermatologist
recommended hair growth supplement
clinically shown to improve your hair
growth visible thickness visible scalp
coverage go to neutralfold.com men to
take their hair Wellness quiz
take their hair Health Wellness quiz say
that five times fast take their hair
Health Wellness quiz take their hair
Health Wellness course identify causes
of your thinning hair neutrophil will
give you a personalized plan for better
hair through whole body Wellness neutral
support I mean what is neutral supports
healthy hair growth from within by
targeting root causes of thinning Citrus
stress hormones environment nutrition
lifestyle metabolism instrument because
just take it if your hair is [__]
take the first step to visibly thick or
healthier hair for limited time neutral
is offering our list is ten dollars so
if your first month's subscription and
free shipping when you go to
neutrophone.com men and enter the promo
code Tim
find out why over 4 000 Healthcare
professionals recommend neutriful for
healthier hair neutrophone.com men
spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com slash men enter
promo code Tim that's neutralfold.com
man promo code Tim no matter where your
adventures uh take you this fall bespoke
post this box of awesome to make it just
that the box of awesome is filmed with
carefully filled with carefully chosen
gear from the best small Brands around
the world let's see what I got this
month I had a great box it was some
camping gear and Outdoorsman stuff just
like I wanted to get started take the
quiz at box of awesome.com your answers
will help them pick the right box of
awesome for you they release new boxes
every month across a ton of different
categories each box is valued at around
70 but you can only pay a fraction of
that price plus with each box of awesome
you're supporting small businesses
ninety percent of everything that comes
in the box is from a small up and coming
brand a lot of them made in the USA
it's free to sign up and you can skip a
month or cancel anytime it's a great
gift to give somebody who's going away
to school or just got married or moved
they think of you every month when they
get that box get 20 off your first
monthly box when you sign up at box of
awesome.com
uh and enter the code Tim Dillon
t-i-m-t-i-l-l-o-n at checkout that's box
of awesome.com code Tim Dillon for 20
off your first box box of awesome.com
code Tim Dillon bluetooth's unique
online service it delivers the same
active ingredients as Viagra Cialis and
Levitra but it's a chewable in tablets
at a fraction of the cost you could take
them anytime day or night so you can go
plan ahead or be ready for an
opportunity whenever it arises the
process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of the
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days the best part
it's all done online no visits to the
doctor's office no awkward conversations
no waiting in line at the pharmacy
Bluetooth tablets are made in the USA
and prepared and shipped direct to your
door in a discreet package everyone uses
it I use it my family uses it everyone
I've met uses this product and they like
it
um Bluetooth wants to help you have
better sex discover your options at
bluetooth.com chew it and do it and
we've got a special deal for our
listeners
try Bluetooth free when you use our
promo code TD at checkout just pay five
dollars shipping that's bluetooth.com
promo code TD to receive your first
month free
that's crazy only five dollars shipping
what
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information and we
thank Bluetooth for sponsoring the
podcast so that's interesting I didn't
realize that they were in the actual
Administration yeah okay a lot of them
are in the administration or have
big Charities like uh you know
um
uh anyway you know run big well you know
like maybe Special Olympics right or you
know that are very have a very strong
important relationships with NIH or with
government of course and that and it's
understandable it's understandable
do you think that the inquiry uh that
the Republicans are opening up into uh
Hunter Biden into Joe Biden into the
Ukraine the burisma the energy stuff do
you think that gets to impeachment oh I
don't know and you know what Tim I kind
of stay away from
because I'm trying to focus on issues
that you know right the kind of values
that people have in common rather than
the inflammatory stuff that keeps us all
apart and uh you know so and and the
other thing is anything
that I say about those issues is kind of
suspect and and really doesn't Advance
you know the understood understood well
let me let me ask you a few more things
I really do appreciate you guys coming
on I do think that you are you make some
very interesting points in a way that
very few people are right now about the
lack of affordability uh the the lack of
housing uh a generation that's kind of
being poisoned with uh food that's being
impoverished with a lot of these um
policies that are not that are going
unchecked where you know you have these
companies being able to buy up large
swaths of of American homes
um
but let's talk for a brief moment about
corporations that do good right like the
pharmaceutical industry
because we should at least mention
because there are good ones and good
ones there are good ones but then there
are you very much
um
want vaccines to be safe this is your
whole thing yeah I'm accused of being
anti-vaxx and that's kind of a
pejorative that is applied to me to
marginalize me and to silence me that oh
he's against all vaccines and that
therefore he's crazy and you shouldn't
listen to anything he says and I've
never said that and I've never felt that
way I feel like vaccines like other
medicine if they work I'm for him
but let's make sure they're properly
tested both for safety and for advocacy
let's make sure that we know
that that product is not causing more
problems then it's averting that's right
oh um is it your intention to take
vaccines away from people oh of course
not and I um
you know I mean I am against mandates
because I'm just go against generally
for bodily autonomy that comes for
abortion or you know people should be
able to make up their own minds
about what to put in their bodies and
how to treat their bodies Etc yeah we
need those personal freedoms but I don't
but otherwise I think that everything
that I say about vaccines of people
actually heard me talk that I'm 99 of
Americans would say
um yeah that makes a lot of sense they
should be tested in in Placebo control
sounds like every other medicine is and
they're not yeah outside of vaccines or
do you think we're over medicated as a
country yeah I mean I know we're over
medicated we take three times the amount
of pills
as anybody does in Europe on average and
and uh medication those pharmaceutical
drugs are now the third leading cause of
death in this country
after heart attacks and cancer so
they're not making us healthier and uh
you know they're of course
there are drugs that help people
um but you know we are over medicated in
this country and part of that is because
of Television advertising of
pharmaceuticals that we are there's only
two nations in the world where it's
legal to advertise pharmaceutical
products on television
that's New Zealand and us and it's
unhealthy it's uh we shouldn't be doing
it it should be illegal it was
in our drugstores if you go to another
country's drugstore there might be two
or three aisles Maybe
our drugstores have 10 aisles of just
just medications and pills and potions
and powders oh we're also the sickest
country in the world right higher
chronic disease well we've still got
that going for us we've still got that
going for us for the sickest
hundreds I mean that might be a good
campaign slogan RFK we are the sickest
country in the world let's fix that
um yeah but it is true that we take a
lot of medication
um we have a lot of uh you know uh
issues in this country you know in terms
of mental health that we don't address
right or like mental health care just
like physical health care is not great
and I think a lot of people you know the
root cause of some of those issues might
be diet they might be situational they
might be clinical they might be
biological but like nobody's figuring
that out no so people are just throwing
pills at people yeah
yeah that's exactly right I mean we you
know listen the industry Right medical
cartel and the pharmaceutical industry
which is the core of that cartel benefit
from having a sick population right and
you know I'm not saying there's somebody
sitting somewhere you know with the
cabal saying let's make everybody sick
or
that's another just like everyone's sick
right if we're making money yeah right
exactly and the more chronic disease the
more drugs they can sell and we've got a
whole generation it's a feedback loop
I mean there's always listen there's 150
million
um uh or 120 million uh benzo
prescriptions every year 120 million
ssris so we're talking about
benzodiazepines talk about things like
Xanax yeah and right now
118 million
Adderall prescriptions yes and so you've
got this 118 million Adderall
prescriptions and benzos and cheese you
know our kids are all like they're
hopped up to The Kills
and a lot of that is because there's
chronic disease rates these kids all
have not only you know they have
physical illnesses they've got
autoimmune diseases like we've never
seen before rheumatoid arthritis
juvenile diabetes uh they've got
a Crohn's disease all these things that
we never heard of before lupus and then
they've got allergic to peanut allergies
suddenly appeared right ubiquitous
around 1989.
asthma exploded all of these allergic
diseases and this might be we might be
over vaccinating people there might we
might not be you know there's a whole
there's
what we do know is it's it happened
around 1989 right and that is when the
vaccine schedule exploded and that's
when all of these uh diseases all those
disease are listed as side effects on
those products right I don't think it's
the I I it that's not the only issue
there's a lot of other
Roundup became ubiquitous around that
timeline near naked white pesticides
pfoas which are flame retardants which
I've litigated on um you know
extensively and they became it went into
every child pajamas all of our furniture
at that time
cell phones appear there's a lot of it
has to be in environmental exposure
right but it's probably just a a
combination of all of these our kids are
now swimming around
in a toxic soup and the food they eat is
contaminated the air they breathe
contaminated the water they drink is
contaminated and it has mental health
issues
impacts it has physical impacts as it
has spiritual impacts ultimately on them
and
you know what what we ought what NIH
ought to be doing is
um looking at very easy for them to do
they have a 42 billion dollar annual
budget they give that
money to 56 000 scientists mainly in
universities and they give them
assignments and say look at these issues
why aren't any of them looking at what
is causing the autism epidemic system
it's really the money unfortunately it's
the money we're gonna we're gonna have
to get people off I mean that's the
problem right because people
are blinded by self-interest to the
point where they just and and that's
your challenges as you know as somebody
running for president is basically how
do you
you know fight that innate desire of of
people to help themselves at the expense
of others yeah well you know one of the
uh interesting unanticipated
benefits I believe of of what happened
during covet where they locked down the
entire country right is it okay it
suddenly becomes permissible now for us
to have big solutions to problems
right so if we fight you know I would
say five years ago that if you found out
that glyphosate which is the you know
the
um
active ingredient of Roundup was causing
uh
he let's say that you know we learned
for sure that it's causing the
um aceliac and grow and uh and gluten
allergies to all the merits yeah that
you're seeing now ubiquitous
at five years ago even if we knew that
definitively
um they'd still say well you know it's
still too important to agriculture to
ban it right and now I think you can say
hey you just shut down the entire
economy with 3.3 million businesses we
locked down
or and close many of them permanently
bankrupt
in order to prevent a disease so let's
you know start preventing chronic
disease that are much worse than covid
right and now with a big program now
because it's kind of I think yeah you
you know it may be now easier for people
to imagine
Banning entire product lines in order to
right then it would have been before
coven yeah so you could go in and say
we're done
you know like things like that right I
mean we grew up eating fast food really
bad our parents would take us there
because they kind of trusted the
government in this way that like you
know they were like if it was that bad
you know I'm sure they would have
figured it out the FDA will give the
kids you know Lunchables or whatever
garbage I mean My Generation grew up
eating all this stuff because the gut
the the people trusted the people in
power to the extent that they were like
hey I guess it's fine it was like big
tobacco yeah yeah
I don't I think it's okay right right
it'll be fine it was killing one out of
every four of us customers who use the
product is directed yeah or 60 years
nobody did anything right and then you
know
um the lawyers came in but you know one
of the things that I'll do
as president as people say that well you
know you can't ban products like that
because they're the manufacturers like
on Santa are too powerful and you know
they'll never let you do it and then but
here's the thing if you have good
science
at you know which I can do at by
controlling NIH
good science that shows okay they're the
reason we're having the Obesity epidemic
is because of high fructose corn syrup
right right and that's you know and it's
causing diabetes causing all these cause
and then all the even if you know the
lobby is up there on Capitol Hill saying
the agriculture Lobby and the porn Lobby
is saying we we can never stop that well
guess what
you have really clear science on the
books that showing that link now the
plaintiff's lawyers are going to come
out of the woodwork you know what's
really interesting all the body positive
stuff a lot of it that's been coming out
has been actually backed by like Nestle
of course I mean this is crazy of course
but I mean we don't know I mean it's
kind of funny but it's like like when
you see something crazy where it's just
like people that are you know it's wild
you know people you know and there's
somebody on the cover of a magazine that
should not be there
[Music]
can we say that it's new that they're
there now it's a new thing now when
they're there A lot of times that you
will look at some of that stuff and it
is sponsored by people that are are
making junk food and I'm not a model
myself I'm not saying you know I'm just
saying that is
true that the the incentives and the
people that are behind certain things
would be fascinating it's interesting
when you look at like the money behind
certain campaigns that spring up
supposedly organically out of nowhere
but that behind those campaigns is
actual money and actual corporate
interests
yeah and then put anyone on the cover
you want I'm not saying that it's uh you
know right that they shouldn't be there
no nothing they shouldn't be there let's
just see you know what's behind of
course choices I just right that's all
I'm saying I know that it's hard I I
mean listen I get it you know and do you
you guys disagree on stuff and that
doesn't mean you don't love each other
this is a whole thing in our country now
people are not allowed to disagree
people are not allowed to say hey this
person feels this way I feel this way
but we're both like Americans like
something happened during covid where we
just got so sad at each other and angry
at each other and and hateful the
discourse is is is is is is is one of
the lowest points
you know that's why when you were asking
me about going on the road that's what I
found so interesting about even going to
South Carolina because
Bobby attracts crowds of Republicans and
Democrats and independents so in one
room you have hundreds of people who you
know
people that I always thought would just
be angry at each other just because
they're in different parties but he's
attracting people that are in different
parties that are saying yeah I'm
listening and I want to listen to how we
can solve this so it's and and you don't
always feel that like perhaps in Los
Angeles that's right I don't feel that
so much I feel like it's very divided it
must be tough for you because I can't
tell you how many people have come up to
us and say you're keeping our marriage
together right it was a you know
trumpers and married to a button
interesting yeah it is interesting
interesting but I mean this is like I I
think it's important for people to see
that
people share a ton of commonalities yeah
you know that's right and and it's like
even more so than our differences that's
exactly what we're yeah everybody want
nobody wants crime everybody wants right
everybody wants some level of equality
that you know everybody to get a fair
shake that view of America they want
healthy kids they don't like you know
the things that we all share the desires
the aspirations for our country for
ourselves everybody wants more freedom
you ask people about these General
issues
and then we're it's almost like you know
and I I said this to Bobby Lee the other
day I said it's almost orchestrated the
you know the the anger you know feels
Orchestra and manipulative that you know
the anger that we're that is is drummed
up between us
you know over issues that affect the
tiny sliver of the population and we're
all fighting over this right you know
whether somebody can use a bathroom or
not
and it's like somebody is jangling the
keys and everybody's attention is on the
keys and meanwhile they're those guys
are robbing the bank
yes and they're telling us look at that
way right you know who's not right about
that right right instead of these actual
big obstructions
problems right yeah they're distracting
us from getting together and say hey
wait a minute you know you guys don't
like each other remember right right
remember you guys hate each other yeah
um well listen I really appreciate both
of you coming I really appreciate you
coming on Cheryl and and and and you
coming on as well I know that you have
such a you know incredibly busy schedule
and you know a lot of the people that I
know are very interested in seeing what
you what you guys have to say you know
because it's like a big and I'm I'm glad
that you're out with him you know
because I know in the beginning it was
you know it's hard it's hard yeah but uh
doing your thing yeah but it's like it's
such a big thing he's doing it's like
running for president yeah I know so
it's you know what I mean it's like
because in the beginning I felt like you
were like this is his thing he's doing
his [__] he's
tinkering around he's running for
president I'm gardening I'll be on set
I'll be on set I'm acting but he's this
is a big thing and I think um you know
like I said everybody loves you and a
lot of people love you
so I think that's the best that's the
best thing where can people go if they
want to support the campaign see you
live donate spread the word of what
you're doing
go ahead they can go to Kennedy
kennedy24.com
kennedy24.com can you follow him on
Instagram and on uh yes
on Ax
yes and Tick Tock yeah and tick ten
everywhere and and um what's uh any
final thing to add because I mean it
does seem like you're getting more
traction and and you're you know you
seem really deadly serious about this
and like you know a lot of people are
out there
um and it's kind of exciting because we
kind of got a mess if you look at the
people running him it's kind of a mess
I know I you know
I
um
you know I mean I I our objective from
the beginning is that how do we bring
people together how do we remind people
that I mean there's polarization is so
toxic in our country more toxic
and more dangerous than any time since
the Civil War right and um we have to
stop you know hating each other we we
need to be able to have debates that are
congenial that are mutually respectful
and be able to you know my uncle
Ted Kennedy has his name on more beats
of legislation than any other senator in
American history and the way that he did
that you know he was on the left wing of
the democratic party but he was friends
with all the Republicans right he would
come home on the weekends with people
like Orrin Hatch who you know I thought
was like Darth Vader because he was so
bad on my issue the environment
and I was like Teddy how can you be
friends with him and he was like I am
you know and if he found
commonality and with Robert Byrd or yeah
he'd bring these guys home and they
would write songs for each other they
would write poetry for each other
was singing songs and writing poetry
that's amazing well no but this is good
this is encouraging to hear yeah and so
this is the way I feel about Putin like
give him a guitar and let's figure it
out we can do this you know RFK thank
you thank you Cheryl thank you so much
we appreciate it of course thank you
guys